we want to fight bad guys it defines Who  I am  we're not saying you have what someone  on TV said it the fact that these people  have these powers is secondary to the  fact that they are a strong unit even  without those powers looks normal to me  am I gonna get happy or gonna make it  laughs the answer is yes closer movies  great so on the edge of right now with  the internet not seeing it in a theater  I think he'd be missing that  technological aspect the visuals are so  beautiful sound everything's very  rewarding she's an advocate for  superheroes were you tricked to know it  was there a baby crying in the audience  last night definitely don't want to miss  the ride  where are you  you